okay let's start uh welcome to our
algorithmic game theory uh session uh
carlos will give the first talk
[Music]
all right thank you uh yeah so my name
is curtis uh i'm talking about delegated
stochastic probing which is giant work
with shading
and so i want to start with a motivating
example for a problem
you can imagine you're a city mayor and
you want to design a public
transportation network
but probably you don't know how to do
this exactly so you delegate the problem
to a contractor but the contractor has
their own interests involved right
so they may like designs that put bus
stops at their own headquarters
or designs that fix roads in their
neighborhoods and things that
generally aren't best for the city but
are best for the contractor
and so we have a mechanism design
problem here how can we incentivize the
contractor
to give us a solution that's good for
the city and not for the contractor
this is delegated search it's a
principal agent type problem
uh where the principal is the mayor and
the agent is the contractor
uh our work is inspired by that of
kleinberg and kleinberg
who develop a model of delegated search
and show some nice approximation
guarantees
now what we notice is that a lot of
delegation problems are very similar to
stochastic probing which is a non-gain
theoretic problem we could broadly
define
as consisting of the set of elements
where each element has a random utility
x there's an outer constraint
eliminating the elements we can probe
where the probe is just to learn the
value of an element
and there's an inner constraint limiting
the sets of elements we can accept
now the procedure is pretty
straightforward we start by probing a
set of elements
subject to the outer constraint and we
learn all their values
and then we accept a subset of probed
elements
this time subject to any constraint
and our goal as you probably expect is
to maximize the sum of the values
of the elements we accept now
what we notice is that kleinberg and
kleinberg their model
is essentially a delegated version of
the stochastic program problem
in particular the problem with k
identically distributed elements
there is no outer constraint and the one
uniform metroid inner constraint
and we can also consider delegating
other stochastic probing problems
like this transportation problem where
we have some number of bus network
designs
some other number of subway network
designs for example
we might have a constant amount of time
available to us
and each design costs a certain amount
of time to evaluate
right so we have a knapsack out of the
instrument
and our inner constraint we want at most
one bus network and at most one
subway network so in general we may want
to delegate arbitrary
stochastic probing problems and this
inspires our definition
of delegated stochastic program so that
model consists of a ground set of
elements e
where each element has a known
distribution over
x and y utilities x for the principal
and y for the agent
we allow x and y to be arbitrarily
correlated or not
but we require that distributions from
different elements
are independent we also have an outer
constraint meaning the sets of elements
that can be probed
the probing constraint and an inner
constraint
limiting the sets of elements that can
be accepted as a solution
our goal is to design a mechanism
maximizing the principle's utility
for the elements they accept and just to
some terms for clarification
we call an element along with its
utilities that triple there
an outcome so when you probe an element
you receive an outcome
and we call a set of outcomes that the
principal could accept
a solution now what we're going to
consider is the following mechanism we
call the single proposal mechanism
and it works by the principle starting
by committing
to a family of acceptable solutions
right and so this means that
for any solution in the set in the set r
if the agent proposes it the principal
commits to accepting it
and for any solution not in r if the
agent proposes it the principal commits
to rejecting it
in response the agent will probe some
elements
and they receive a set of outcomes as
then they'll propose
a solution which is a subset of the
elements
of the outcomes they approached now if
that solution is acceptable to the
principal
then they'll accept it as they committed
to doing and both principal and agent
get their respective utilities
but otherwise the principal will reject
the proposal
and this is the status quo so we
consider this as them both getting zero
utility
as an example of this to make it kind of
concrete consider this example where
elements are the nodes of the graph
our outer constraint is four uniforms we
can probe up to four elements
and our inner constraint is independent
sets so we can accept any independent
set of the graph
if this problem were fully defined we
would also know the distributions of
elements
but i'll ignore that for simplicity so
a reasonable strategy for the principle
is to set a threshold in this case
they'll set a threshold of 10
for acceptable sets for acceptable
solutions
in response the agent will per
some elements which on that they probe
they determine they
learn the value for the principal and
for the agent of that element
and then now we can see that solution cd
in this example
is the principal's favorite available
solution
solution ae is the agent's favorite
available solution
but this solution while it's the agent's
favorite
it's not acceptable to the principal
right so the principal would reject it
if it was proposed
and so the agent will actually propose
their favorite from the acceptable
solutions
which in this case is a d and it's
really a middle ground between the
interests of the principal and the agent
so they'll propose that and principal
committed to excepting it
now what we're interested in our work is
characterizing a particular
notion of approximation that we call the
delegation gap
it's a comparison between the delegated
utility of the principal
which is their utility when they
delegate and
their non-delegate utility which is
versatility
when they search on their own under the
same constraints as the agent
so this is the same as their utility
when they solve the stochastic probing
problem
now the delegation gap just measures the
worst case ratio between these two
in optimality of course and you can see
or you might be able to see that it's a
stronger notion
than the standard notion of
approximation
as a quick overview of our results
coming here
we showed that single proposal
mechanisms the mechanisms
we discuss are just as powerful as
general mechanisms
we show that our model of delegation can
be reduced
to a combination of profit inequalities
and adaptivity gaps of a certain form
and using results in these two areas we
get some
ways first we show that there are
constant delegation gaps
for problems with downward closed outer
constraints
and inner constraints that are the
intersection of a constant number of
metroids
so this is a really broad class of
problems that we get constant gaps for
and we also get a one-half delegation
gap for a generalization of the problem
of kleinberg and kleinberg
and this just generalizes their results
to kind of a broader model
finally we briefly investigate
randomized mechanisms
battery mechanisms and we show that they
sometimes outperform deterministic ones
but not in general now to end i think
our work opens up a lot more questions
than it closes
so i want to leave you with some of
those questions first of all
are these factors tight we only know
that the one half is tight
for the instances i described briefly
but we don't know for any others
how to compute the strategies uh needed
to get these delegation gaps
what if elements have a probate instead
of or in addition to the outer
constraint
what if the principal can incentivize
the agent by making payments
for solutions that they prefer can they
do better
and finally what if the principal
delegates to multiple agents at the same
time
you might imagine that they can get
agents to compete with each other
and this could give the principal a
better solution overall
so if you're interested in any of this
please see our long-form video or the
paper
and that's all i have thank you
very nice if anyone has a super quick
question they can go and otherwise the
next speaker
can share the screen
no are you getting the next thought yep
great
please go ahead okay hi i'm noah and
i'll be talking about relaxing common
belief for social networks
so the central idea that i want to start
with is an idea that might be familiar
to many of you
and that's the idea of common knowledge
and informally we say a proposition is
common knowledge when
everyone knows that it's true everyone
knows that everyone knows that it's true
everyone knows that everyone knows that
everyone knows that it's true
and so on so we have these levels and at
each level we add and everyone knows to
the beginning
or to the previous level and we have an
infinite number of levels and that's an
informal definition of common knowledge
and common knowledge is important in
game theory because it undergirds
strategic coordination
so typically uh when we want when we're
interested in seeing how agents
coordinate with one another
we we will assume that they have common
knowledge of some proposition
and that supports their ability to
coordinate so for example in the
standard game theoretic setting
we'll assume that agents have common
knowledge of the payoffs of the game
and of the rationality of the other
agents and that undergirds their ability
to coordinate
on for example a nash equilibrium
now common knowledge is is known and
thought to be
a pretty strict requirement so it's
sometimes people are uncomfortable
making that assumption that agents have
common knowledge really of anything at
all
and various ideas to on how to relax
common knowledge have been explored
and an important one is the idea of
common belief which was explored in a
paper by monitor and salmon in 1989
that's really central to our work
and they propose that something should
be common belief when everyone believes
with probability p
that it's true everyone believes with
probability p that everyone believes the
probability p that it's true and so on
so basically what they've done is
they've relaxed the definition of common
knowledge by taking the word
nose at every place that appears and the
definition i just gave
and replacing it with the phrase
believes with probability p
and although i said uh that common
belief is not the only
relaxation of common knowledge that's
been explored
in some sense it really is the right
relaxation of common knowledge
because when common knowledge is
approximated by common belief
we see that agents are able to
approximately coordinate
in the way that they would coordinate uh
if they had common knowledge of the
thing that they have common belief in
uh and this isn't true for many of the
other proposed relaxations of common
knowledge so for example
uh common belief in payoffs and mutual
rationality
allows for approximate coordination on
the nash equilibrium
so we'd like to take these ideas uh
these recursive reasoning ideas like
common knowledge and common belief
and apply them in social networks uh
where we think they're important for
example
for the formation and changing of social
norms which involves this type of
recursive reasoning where you have to
think about what other people think
about you
and the problem is that the key notions
aren't useful in many natural graphs
especially graphs that we'd want to use
as social network models
so for example on sparse graphs
population level phenomena like common
belief will not arise or very unlikely
to arise
um and so a first pass that this might
say well what if we
we relax the idea that it's a population
level phenomena
and that sort of was explored by michael
chad in 1999 and 2000
uh where he looked at a network revolt
game setting
uh that required local common knowledge
for coordination so agents were
forming common knowledge with their
neighbors in the graph but it turned out
that finding pockets of this local
common knowledge reduced to finding
cliques
uh and even in dense graphs large
cliques will not be present or in many
dense graphs like
an erdos-renyi random graph with p
equals one-half being the probability
for each edge appearing
uh large cliques will not be present
even though agents have a lot of
information so they won't be able to
coordinate in large groups in this model
even though you might expect that they
should be able to
so the idea in our paper is that we want
to sort of synthesize
these two uh areas of research and in a
way that transcends their limitation
and the key notion here is we call
factional belief
and we say factional belief relaxes
common belief
uh in the same way or a similar way to
the way common belief relaxes common
knowledge where we take in the
definition of common belief
uh and every time it said everyone we've
replaced that with there is a faction of
agents
and you can see that written out on the
slide here
and the idea that we explore is that
factional belief undergirds partial
approximate coordination
in a similar way that common belief
undergirds approximate coordination and
ultimately that common knowledge
undergirds strategic coordination
and in particular we explore that
connection in the setting of network or
full games that are really inspired by
that work of chat that i mentioned
earlier
so the network revolt game model that we
explore
we have uh i'll introduce the model
briefly uh we'll have a graph g that
represents a social network that's
common knowledge among the agents
and each agent will have a type that
falls into one of three buckets alpha
new or chi and we'll see why these names
are named the way they are on the next
slide
but the idea is that types are assigned
according to some state of the world
which describes a probability
distribution over the types
and the game proceeds in such a way
where the agents will commit to a peer
strategy
that maps an object called their context
to an action revolt or yield
sort of participating in the revolt or
staying home
and the context which is the key key
item in our paper
is the the information that the agents
have which is their type and the types
of all their neighbors
and intuitively we've set up the game
inspired by the work of che
so that there's a natural strategy for
each agent based on their type and these
strategies give the types their names
which is that agents of type alpha
should always revolt agents of type nu
should never revolt
and agents of type kai should
conditionally revolt depending on their
beliefs about how other agents will act
so the agents of type chi are the ones
that have to engage in this recursive
reasoning
uh and in particular we have the agents
of type chi have
two thresholds a belief threshold and a
participation threshold
where they would want to revolt if they
sufficiently believe
that participation in the remote will be
sufficiently high and they would prefer
not to revolt if either of those two
conditions is not met
so given those strategies the the game
proceeds as follows which is first
agents commit to a strategy
then nature determines the state and
agents are assigned types independently
at random
according to the distribution that's
described by the state then agents
observe their context
and apply their strategy to choose an
action
and we're interested in the equilibria
of these games in particular we're
interested
in finding the largest equilibrium uh
the largest revolt that's supported in
any equilibrium and it turns out that
these
revolts are supported by symmetric
equilibria in which the agents adopt the
same strategy which are pretty much the
strategies that i've described
previously and that's why those
strategies turned out to be so important
so uh in this model what we're able to
do first independently of the model we
define
a notion of factional belief so i've
given an informal definition but in
order to to do anything rigorous about
it we need to
formally define what it means for a
group of agents to be a faction
uh which we do in the paper and we show
that this definition can be used to
analyze revolt games on general graphs
uh by exploring those network revolt
games that i just described and
providing an
algorithm that characterizes
in almost all cases what the largest
revolt supported in any equilibrium will
be
and the probability with which that
revolt will occur
and we show that surprisingly it's
sufficient for our algorithm to only
have access to the degree sequence of
the network and not the actual network
structure itself
although that result is pretty sensitive
to our assumption that the types are
distributed independently at random
and lastly uh we use some simulated
network data to
explore how the equilibrium of all sizes
vary as we
vary underlying parameters of networks
and the model
so i had to skip over a lot of the
details in this short talk but
i'd encourage you if you're interested
to look at our
longer video where we're able to get in
more to it or you can find our full
version of the paper
uh with this archive identifier here or
feel free to follow up with grant or i
uh after the session thanks
very nice um can the next speaker
kimberly can you set up please
okay before we go for the uh third talk
let's just uh take a 30 seconds
uh break and take a deep breath
okay we're ready now uh all right
can you hear me okay great um
so uh here's my talk and this was joint
work with
matt weinberg so um let's suppose that
we're in the last round of a chess
tournament and there are exactly three
players
perfect score and we'll call them a b
and kimberly
um so a and b are playing each other in
this last round and they're going to
draw their game
and they know that kimberly is going to
win um so if
everything precedes normal she'll get
first place and they'll tie for second
place
but if a resigns on purpose then maybe b
has a chance of tying for first place or
getting first place after tiebreak
um so if a does this then it's not very
honest
but it does increase their um chances of
first as a group
so this is an example of collusion um
and we want to know if we can design a
tournament rule that minimizes the
effects of collusion or
upper bounds but what is a tournament
rule um
okay so when we formally define
tournaments we consider round-robin
tournaments with only wins and losses
so a tournament can be represented by a
complete directed graph
with um an edge from a to b if a beats b
and then the tournament rule takes in
this graven up it's a winner usually
like uses some sort of probability
distribution over the players um
to maybe break a tie but um if a rules
condor stay consistent then
if there exists a player who beats every
other player then that rule always
declares that player to be the
tournament winner
um so in this diagram as the
conversation winner uh they beat
everyone else
so a conor state consistent rule would
declare a the winner
um but in this tournament it's not as
obvious who the winner should be
okay um so then what is tournament
manipulation
um all right so let's say there's a
group of two players who wants to cheat
in the tournament but they can only
control the outcome of the match that
they play against each other
so we call the tournament too strongly
non-manipulable
if a change in the outcome of this match
doesn't increase their collective
chances of winning at
all so as it turns out you can't have a
rule that's both conversate consistent
and strongly non-motivatable
or s m so since we can only keep one we
want to keep conor's
consistent since it seems more important
so we define a rule as
two s m alpha if two players can't
increase their chances of winning
collectively
by more than alpha and then previous
work shows that one third is a lower
bound than alpha
um and that there exists rules that are
two us and one third
um so here's a quick example so we have
this three player tournament where
everyone beats each other in this circle
like this
um so we're not sure who should win but
we do know that any rule has to assign
someone a win probability of at least
one third um so let's say c
wins with probability at least one third
um but then let's say
that a loses to be on purpose and then b
suddenly wins with probability one
um we've let's assume that the world's
kind of say consistent um
so now because b beats both people b
definitely wins so a and b have
increased their collective chances of
winning by at least one-third
so this is unavoidable
however um what if the outcome of each
match is uniformly at random
and then a and b don't know who's won
what match um when they have to
figure out what they're going to do to
collude so now they don't really know
what to do
and the scenario is a little more
complicated so most previous work on
tournament rules um
assumes that including players know the
outcome of every match
but this is actually worst case scenario
um because often in real life they don't
so we're going to look at tournaments
where no one knows the outcome of any
match
before they have to collude they just
have some general idea of
what the players might do so we consider
independent
probabilistic tournaments where the
outcome of each match occurs with the
probability drawn from the range
one-half minus epsilon to one-half plus
epsilon
um so we want to know if there's lower
bound for alpha here too
and if we can construct rules that meet
this lower bound and in fact
our main result consists of a bound and
two rules that meet this bond which is
epsilon over three plus two epsilon
squared over three
um so in the paper we develop a useful
framework to analyze recursive
tournament rules
and we use this framework to analyze two
roles um randomized desk match
and randomized single elimination
bracket rcb has already been shown to be
2 s
m3 when applied to the deterministic
tournament in previous work
so both of those are structured like
this they take a group of players and
then
every round they select a bunch of
matches for the players and then
the players play and then they eliminate
the losers
so first let's talk about the proof
framework um so if we call the colluding
players u and v
we notice that at the start of the
tournament there's usually a non-zero
chance that you and v are able to
include and gain probability
and then every round something happens
maybe they both stay in the tournament
and they can still collude in the future
so we call this a recursive event
um or maybe they play each other so we
call this a terminal event because they
can't um collude after they've played
each other since one of them will be
eliminated
but they can collude during the match so
it's a bad terminal event
um if one of them is eliminated by
someone else then we call that a good
terminal event
um because they didn't collude and then
another type of good terminal event
um occurs if they become identically
distributed uh so the gist of this
is that basically um once they beat all
remaining players with identical
probabilities then it doesn't matter
who wins the match between you and v
because the probability of the winner
winning the overall tournament
is the same either way um
so we would like to bound the maximum
probability game that you and v can
achieve via collusion
and using these definitions um we've
created
uh this expression v times c over b plus
g that actually serves as an upper bound
given that you're able to find
c b and g um as they are defined
so a brief example here skip over
one of the proofs but um we analyze rcp
in the term sorry in the deterministic
setting
using this proof framework um so rcp
works basically like this if the number
of original players in the tournament
is not a power of two then it pads a
tournament with dummy players who always
lose
um so playing one is equivalent to
taking a bite basically
um until the number of players is a
power of two and then it's clear for
this rule that
c is an upper bound i mean c equals one
is a valid upward bound because
you can gain like probability of one at
most maybe
um and then a bad terminal event occurs
when u and v play
so that's one over n prime minus one
where n prime is the number of players
after padding
and then uh for g uh it is two over n
prime minus one
and the description is a little
complicated um
you can read about in the paper it's
also on this slide but yeah ultimately
what you get after plugging it all in
is one-third and since that does match
the value
obtained in previous work which also
used a separate proof method
that um is a pretty good sign for us so
in the general case
uh where we don't make any assumptions
about epsilon um we want to find a
better bound for c
since one is very generous so we notice
that if you and v play in match
then whoever wins has to beat a certain
set of players in order to win the
tournament
and this is independent of who wins the
match so it's the same stat which we
call the gauntlet
which means that the difference in their
win probabilities is at most two epsilon
because of this expression
over here um and then the gains
from the bad term moment is two epsilon
uh it's max out of two epsilon times one
half plus epsilon because um
of the probability that the original
uncolluded tournament is identical to
the tournament under collusion
and then the general case finding b and
g are pretty similar
um full details are in the paper um and
we do end up arriving at this value of
epsilon over three plus two epsilon
squared over three um after we plug
everything
into the expression that we got and then
there
is um a proof of the tightness of this
bound using a similar triangle
tournament as the one we saw before this
time with probabilistic edges basically
um
there's not actually time to get into
the details here but the general idea is
we assign win probabilities to each of
the cycles and then the conjure say
winners um
when there's a kind of say winner we
know who wins already so then when you
take the average
of the expected probability gained from
the players from all three groups of
possible
colliding pairs um then we end up
getting an average value of
epsilon over three plus two epsilon
squared over three which matches our
value from before and because this is an
average value there must exist
one group of colluding players that can
achieve this value
when when colluding so
in conclusion we found a tight bound on
probability gain via manipulation
for consciously consistent tournament
roles um when applied to independent
probabilistic tournaments
and we've also developed a useful
recursive framework to help analyze
recursive roles
and then fusionwork might use this
framework for other tournaments
or find ways to analyze non-independent
tournaments or previously studied rules
that didn't work as well with our
framework
uh yeah so yeah i guess that's it and
i'll take questions later
fantastic i don't need to do anything uh
go ahead please
yeah can you hear me fine
cool perfect thanks um okay so hi
everyone my name is
judah and i'm postdoc at upenn right now
uh today i'm going to tell you about my
work on pipeline interventions
and this is joint work with ashwar ari
naturalized warren sampat cannon
and aaron rod who are also a man
so today i want to tell you about
fairness and i want to tell you about
fairness in pipelines
so the reason i want to do so is because
in real life decisions buy and decisions
about individuals are
not going to be made in isolation rather
these decisions are going to be made
throughout the life of an individual
and decisions at different stages of
someone's life are going to have an
effect on each other
and they're going to compose with each
other if i look for example
at the education in the job market
pipeline we can see how
each decision is going to fit into the
next which preschool i'm going to
is going to affect which cause i have
access to which is going to affect what
college i'm getting into which is going
to affect what kind of jobs i can get
and so when you're thinking about
fairness this can lead to
difficulties and one of the reasons for
this is because disparities and
inequality of access to opportunities
can arise at each and
several stages of such pipelines and
then those disparities are going to
compose
the current opportunities that i have
today are restricted by previous
disparities that act based
or if you want to look at the flip side
of this picture disparities that i'm
facing today
may have a long-term effect on the
futures of future opportunities that i
will get
and even worse we know that those
disparities can arise even at the very
early stages of such a pipeline
if i look at the education pipeline we
know that those disparities can
arise even in the preschool level
so the question here that i want to ask
is where are we going to intervene to
eliminate or at least reduce those
disparities
one proposition is to in the education
pipelines to intervene
at the college admission level but
however that's often going to be too
late
if disparity starts at the preschool
level then it seems that
interventions earlier in the pipeline
are going to be needed
at the same time if i only intervene
very early in the pipeline it might be
hard to control the downstream and the
long-term effects
of such an intervention and so what we
proposed in this paper
is that it actually may be valuable to
intervene at several levels
rather than myopically and at a single
level of such a pipeline
now if you want to do so you need to
understand how interventions and
different stages are going to compose
and you need to understand how this is
going to inform the optimal design of
interventions at several levels of such
pipeline
if your goal is to improve outcomes and
to reduce disparities across groups
so in this paper our first main
contribution is to provide authority
and stylized model to think about such
pipelines
and our model is going to be a graphical
model which is comprised of several
layers
so we have agents that are going to
begin in the starting layer
and the starting layer is going to be
comprised of several nodes
and you can think of each node you can
think of different starting nodes
as different starting groups or
sub-populations or
social economic statuses in your problem
then the agents are going to evolve
throughout the graph and they're going
to evolve through subsequent layers
and you can think of each subsequent
layer as a stage of life in this problem
and it's not
as the outcome of a given stage of life
for example
so a stage of one layer could correspond
to your education level to your college
education
and the outcome could correspond to
different levels of education or
different majors or
those kinds of issues and finally the
agents are going to
end up in the final layer each node on
this final layer
is going to have a reward and the reward
is going to be this color measure
of the quality of the outcome that
corresponds to that
node
so i've told you about what the graph
looks like i haven't told you exactly
how agents are going to move
uh through the graph and between two
layers and so the way
individuals are going to progress
through the graph is through stochastic
transitions between layers
and those stochastic transitions are
going to govern the probability that
you're going from a node on a current
layer to a node on the next layer
and that's where we're going to model
disparities between populations
uh because basically you can give
different groups different probabilistic
paths to different reward nodes
throughout the graph
so you could imagine that some advantage
calculations from the beginning are
going to have
high probability path to high reward
nodes
versus it could be that some other
populations that are more disadvantaged
are going to have
higher probability path to lower reward
nodes
and then our intervention model in this
pipeline is going to be the following
we'll take the point of view of a
centralized designer who can
intervene at any and several stages of
such a pipeline
and an intervention is going to consist
into changing the stochastic transitions
between any two layers
obviously you don't get to do this for
free you're going to incur a cost to
change transitions between any two
successive layers
and our centralized designer is going to
have a maximum budget that can be
invested
across changing all transitions between
all
two subsequent layers
and then in this paper our second main
contribution is going to be algorithmic
and we provide dynamic programming
algorithms for
finding approximately optimal
interventions in this problem
what i mean by optimality here is with
respect to two different objectives
the first one is that we're trying to
maximize the social welfare and the
expected reward of
population given that there's going to
be a starting distribution of our
starting nodes so this distribution is
going to cover the probability that a
given agent starts in
any given node or any given
subpopulation at the beginning of your
graph
and this objective is really the best
that you can achieve at the level of the
whole population
but it does not really tell you anything
about how the welfare is going to be
split between different sub-populations
and so it may actually just ignore
minority or disadvantaged populations
which is why we also look at the maximum
objective
and this maximum objective is going to
maximize the welfare of the worst off
group
so if you think about the maximum
objective for a second it really tells
you
that the maximum objective is going to
be the highest expected rework
that you can achieve simultaneously for
all the subpopulations
and if you were to take the welfare of
the worst
population and try to improve that
welfare there would be another
population that would have
less welfare than the maximum objective
and i want to conclude this talk
basically on saying that we're not
solving all the questions here
rather this is just trying to give a
first step in the first model to show
that we can think about
those kind of issues and interventions
in pipeline in the theoretical in
algorithmic and in the formal manner
and there are a lot of interesting
future directions and i hope that our
work is going to inspire a lot of
interesting
and important research on fairness and
pipelines
some of those directions are the
following uh first of all you can
imagine that agents from different
subpopulations
may face different transitions even if
they end up in the same node in the
graph so you can imagine that like
men and women may not have the same
opportunities even if they reach the
same outcomes in life
you can also imagine that transitions
may not be stochastic but they're going
to involve strategic elements
because in practice decisions don't just
happen to agents and individuals
but agents are going to make choices are
going to make decisions and are going to
try to choose a path
through the pipeline it would be
interesting also to build up to more
complex reward models in which different
people might have different utilities
and might want different outcomes
and could be very interesting to see
what happens if you don't have a
centralized designer but rather you have
non-centralized designers and you have
different entities that can intervene
at different stages possibly
independently of each other
and if you want to hear more technical
details about this work
please refer to the full version of the
talk
thank you very much for listening um
yeah let me know if you have any
questions
uh very nice i think we're ready for our
last talk um
i just want to remind you after the last
stop we'll have a short
uh panel with some uh with some poetry
and also a discussion
and even one song uh who's presenting
the next talk
is it
okay great thank you
so can you hear me i can barely hear you
if you can speak it louder i think
benefit everyone
is it better now
okay so hi i'm fungi
i'm going to share with you one of my
work in information in the station
and this is a joint work with grant so
i would like to use these eight minutes
to tell you some interesting technique
that we use from
information theory which might be
interesting in general tcs audience
and if you are more interested in
information the station
feel free to refer uh to see the full
length talk
so so the problem that we're trying to
understand is how can we collect
information from agents
and one main challenge is that
oftentimes it's very difficult for us to
verify whether they
are telling us the truth or not their
information can be
subjected or private
so one main idea is in this area
is called peer predictions so the
observation is that
agent signals are correlated so suppose
other people are telling the truth then
we can use their informations
to verify whether another agent is still
in the truth or not
so in this case we are considered two
agents and it's a bob
that we want to collect their daily
coping times
so the question that we are interesting
is we're trying to come up with a
mechanism
which pays agents some amount of money
based on their reports
such that if they tell us the truth they
are going to get the maximum amount of
money
so to put it in uh to put it a little
more formal
we're trying to ensure the truth tell us
the truth telling is a bayesian national
equivalence
and you also have the highest payment so
you cannot
uh agents cannot call corrupts such that
they get more
payments so
in this talk i'm going to tell you uh
one
very powerful framework called mutual
formation framework
and how can we use mutual information to
design
pure prediction maximizations and then
i'm going to tell you about
our main observation to introduce
regional statistics
to mechanism designs
so the model that we consider is called
multi-test setting
and there's two very important
assumptions that is commonly made in
previous work
the first one is a prior similar task
that is we consider suppose we're trying
to collect the daily commute times
we consider for each days the commute
times for ls above are grown for a
common distribution pxy
and this distribute this sample is iid
distributed and the second assumption is
consistent strategy or uniform strategy
that is added strategy on each day's
reports
only depends on that they signal
and this strategy is uniform across all
tasks
so with these two
assumptions in the models one big
observation is that
you can think their strategy as a noisy
channels uh
so that is padded strategy is a noisy
channel
then if you are familiar with
information theory this channel is just
adding noise to your
your original random variables
that is if x and y is bobs and added
signal
if alice apply some strategy on her
report on her signal and make a report
then why x and x has from a markov
chains
so that is uh the signal
so this will ensure that you have these
spatial structures with these
observations
uh you can use data processing qualities
between their reports so in particular
if you can majors the mutual formation
between the reports
the data processing quality tells you
that the mutual information
between their signals is always greater
than the mutual information between
their reports
so in this case they can only maximize
their payments
when telling us the truth
and in general this data processing
quality can be held for general
five mutual formations so instead of
using uh a convex function
that is uh phi a equal to a dot a we can
use arbitrary convex function phi
and the financial information is defined
as follows
so with list observations
uh the mission information framework
tells you that if you can pay the mutual
formations between agents reports
then we got a pretty good mechanism in
particular true selling is
uh based in h equivalence and you will
pay the highest amounts
to each agent so
are we done here the issue that
so the remaining issue is how can
estimates their mutual formations
we use a very uh
observation that we have is not new but
i think it's very
interesting and powerful that may be
interesting to other people as well
so we try to convert the estimation
problem to an optimization problem
the first observation is that we can
evaluate a complex function
by an optimization problem with respect
to its complex conjugate
so if we plug in these formulations to
the final mutual formations
we can convert the evaluation problems
to a optimization problem over
a convex a set of functions k
which may bring a pair of reports to a
real value
so we will call these scoring functions
and this value will be maximized when
your k-star have this phone
and we will call this an ideal scoring
functions
so these formulations enable us to
translate the problem into an
optimization problem
and in the computer science viewpoints
you can
think k as a distinguisher between two
distributions
the joint distributions and the product
of marginal distributions
so in this case if your split report
space
is very simple you can just evaluate
this
organization problems directly
if your joint distribution is simple for
some joint
some parametric models for example
gaussian distribution
then we have some spatial structure for
for these k functions
so here is an example if alias and box
signal are drawn
for joining gaussian distributions if
we're trying to measure the general
mutual information
then the resulting scoring ideal scoring
function will be
a quadratic function so this can reduce
the hours we can consider a smaller
space
of possible scoring functions
and finally you can consider later
variable model that
uh that trying to approximate
this uh of trying to approximate these
scoring functions
and on the other hand you can this ideal
scoring function have
uh is al also highly correlated with
some
uh known properties in the machine
learning literature
so first of all the ideal scoring
functions depend
on the ratio of the conditional
distribution and the prior distributions
so this quantity is well known as the
observed to expected ratio
and finally it would be sufficient for
us to
estimate the soft classifier which is
probability of y conditional
x and this value is basically we're
trying to aggregate
all the agents report to predict one
agent signals
and so this can be easily extend to uh
uh arbitrary number of agents as well
so i think that's end of my talks thank
you
uh very nice let's thank all the
speakers again
and and we have we have so we have a
panel
um discussion now i i thought that one
way uh while you're all thinking about
the
questions they want to discuss on the
panel i thought uh it would be nice to
start the panel
uh asked uh each of the speakers to uh
write a short uh poem about their
work so you can remind yourself about
the the paper and then
um and and then and then we'll
we'll discuss some questions that you
come up with so while you're all
thinking about questions um
uh uh the first paper uh curtis did you
write a poem
yeah uh yeah but okay shout out so
so please want to share share a screen
and share that one
let me do that
uh yeah so here can you see that
too lazy to probe so you delegate are
you destined to lose
is that your fate much utility you need
not forfeit
with adaptivity gaps and inequalities of
profit
i think that gives a very nice overview
very nice uh
yeah so i wrote a haiku for relaxing
common belief for social networks so
here it is
coordination breeds recursive reasoning
what you think i think
oh these haikus sometimes really need to
stare them for a little bit to
really get the
okay uh kim really
uh yeah so i didn't know we were gonna
have to read them out loud otherwise i
would have written
a shorter one um
maybe you guys can just look at it
matt do you wanna do you want to read it
sure i can try a dramatic reading if uh
kimberly you don't want to read it
yourself i don't think i want to read
this is like 20 lines oh my god
do you want me to or too long
i haven't seen this before so apologies
uh said you
i know it's cheating but i think we
should collude said v
i agree even though it's kind of rude
and unfair
still who cares but it is indeed a shame
that we don't know the outcome of any
single game
said you we do know that games are
closely fought so a win guaranteed might
help us out a lot
said v so we're all equal no one's
really strong
said you basically by plus or minus
epsilon
said v well that sucks that's not good
news to me
given the rule they're using which is
rseb
the most that we will get out of working
collectively is epsilon plus two epsilon
squared
all over three which really isn't worth
the loss
of all my dignity said you that's not
much
but it's not nothing at all said v
recall that epsilon is surely very small
said you what a shame life is really
very cruel
if only they had gone and used a
different sort of rule
thank you kimberly for writing that
that was fantastic where uh um kimberly
if you can
unsheriff right now we're actually going
to do a little switch in the order i'll
let uh
i'll keep up for last and um uh
funny did you write a poem
sorry i didn't prepare for that oh it's
okay
um okay so so so uh i'll let uh
take it uh um all right disclaimer i've
yet said that
you could either write a haiku or go for
any other form of
art so i did the most ridiculous thing
i've done in a long time
uh also i'm going to need to share sound
how do i do that yes
don't judge me too much
[Music]
i started cross
today
[Music]
[Music]
can hate decisions
are composed
from here back to your grave
and i want to intervene
to make pipelines more fair
[Music]
can you solve this crap
[Music]
everything i know
is unfair
[Music]
i won't let you down
[Music]
i will make things fair
all right
that that was a truly fantastic those uh
great artistic uh um part of the panel
um all right
i i i have a couple of questions uh
people have already sent for the
um panel system but if you think of some
uh please uh continue to send them um
so so the the first question uh and
any anyone on the on the panels uh
speakers co-authors uh anyone else
feel free to jump after it so the first
question had to do with um
relating these really cool results that
we saw to um
uh practice what are some things that
might apply what are some
barriers uh changes in the model you
would do
i can take a stab at that i think um
for our model one of the biggest
barriers to really applying it
is probably just a lack of information
because
the principal would have to be aware of
all of the possible elements
that can be probed and have very good
information about their distributions
so having results that don't need such
exact information
could be really useful to applying this
anyone else have thoughts yeah
so i think in our in our setting we
consider multi-test setting
which assumes that the signal or iid
throughout the test and this assumption
i think is too
strong and in particular agents may
trying to learn
the dynamics and improve their strategy
as times goes by
so consistent strategy is not making
too much sense in the practice
yeah so for our paper we thought about
tournaments
where their around robin and there's
number of matches that you
don't know the results of yet um whereas
in real life
usually um i feel like you often know
the results of some of the matches and
not some others
so maybe more a true life model would
reflect that
kimberly if you only knew your own
results
would would there be anything to hold if
i only knew my own results
oh
[Music]
it's hard to say i mean in our work we
don't rely on knowing
any results um so
yeah i am not really sure about that
knowing your only your own results and
only that would still be a kind of weird
thing right
like what you would really want is for
the algorithm to also
design the order in which games are
played and then you only know what came
before
possibly even adaptively
in in in in a sports setting it's more
of a show right
so you want everyone to see the results
but uh you can think you can think of
some setting where you care more about
um
this preventing strategizing than um
than the show that's fair and and then
you could hide the result
um maybe maybe you can still broadcast
the results and if if it's like uh
something that's all the games are
happening in one day you can back slow
broadcast the result on tv
to audience which is now to the
participants right there in isolation or
whatever
that's true
so i think just just to quickly
elaborate on what kimberly was saying is
that um
i agree with what she said that for the
positive results
were not you know she's not assuming any
knowledge of anything
for the lower bound you could maybe the
lower bound requires saying oh on this
graph you can't do better because here's
a manipulation that requires them to
know
what happens in all the other matches so
it could be
that with an assumption like that you
can do something better but the positive
results would still hold
and anyone else maybe someone has like a
positive thing about how
how their theory results maybe can some
somehow applied to practice oh i was
actually just going to say that i
mentioned some of the directions that i
wanted to actually follow in future work
it's another positive thing rather just
trying to extend those results
and of all directions that i mentioned i
think the one that's
most important to me and the one that i
really want to fall out on is
where even if you arrive at the same
note throughout the craft if you're
coming from different populations you
may
face different transitions you may face
different
opportunities and i want to see how you
can deal with this because that's
something that really happens in
practice
so for the the paper with feng yi on
determining this mutual information
this paper is is in some ways a very
practical paper it was very hard to get
um theoretical results that there are
new theoretical results but a lot of
times
um in in the models it's
they don't capture the fact that you
want as much information as you can
about a person's signal
in order to to suss out the difference
between people that are slacking and
people that are trying as much as
possible
in equilibrium everyone tries and
everything works and it's good
in practice you want to to learn that
with as much accuracy as possible
and we we feel that this
way of doing it is actually uh has real
promise to do a lot better than
the previous results in practice
uh great great if you can you can come
back
i want to say that the other session is
is uh uh
starting in a few seconds um we'll
we'll hang out here for a little bit
longer but if you want to uh
hear more talks um i don't promise i'll
have poems but otherwise
the papers look very very nice um
i i have one more uh contributed
question for those of you uh
staying um so uh
this this is a a question from uh
about uh modeling agents as
as rational versus um as
uh stochastic i guess that's uh
or or maybe maybe there's some somewhere
in between that we should
and you can elaborate on that funny so
um i noticed that recently there's more
and more people trying to design
mechanism for
multi-aging system and they make some
behavioral assumption of men
for example the model in my mind is like
inference mechanizations like assuming
contagion spreading certain way
and trying to come up with algorithm for
that and i'm wondering
um oh so
i wonder how should we handle those
assumptions
and how much should we do to improve
those things or
we should spend more effort on verifying
those assumptions
or relaxing those assumptions that was
mine
as you know
anyone has any thoughts insights
i i tend to think it's probably
generally a safe assumption that agents
are
rational but uh what's more uncertain
is what their incentives are what their
goals are
and that may be unknown even to them
but i think we can still model them as
rational just with kind of
a complicated set of goals or interests
i i don't have any anything super clever
to add i think i think we
think was a great panel if if anyone has
any last minute
questions or or another poem uh feel
free to share
uh otherwise i think i think i'll log
off but you can all
uh uh stay on the call and hang out and
discuss further thank you very much
everyone thanks again to the speakers